a barrage of Russian missiles was shot
down over Ukraine but clearly not all of
them one destroyed a residential
high-rise in Oman
Sarge lubinsky says his neighbors who
moved in when he did 30 years ago are
all gone
has left he says
the death toll more than 20 and climbing
includes four children
President Vladimir zielinski called for
a moment of silence but also called upon
the Free World to remain committed to
Ukraine's fight
Russia must lose and its leadership must
be punished he said
there are signs that the expected
Ukrainian counter-offensive in the East
is about to start the military is
seeking out Russians with drones as
Ukraine awaits more NATO weapons like
this howitzer
super easy
there super says this artillery
Commander better than the old Soviet era
models were able to push the Russians
back and move the guns more quickly he
says
the counter-offensive will be crucial to
demonstrate to Nato that with its help
Ukraine can succeed says this analyst
the Western world has given an enormous
amount of Aid defensive weapons and so I
think it needs to demonstrate to all of
its allies that it can use those weapons
to good effects and push back uh Russian
troops
today the pope lamented what's happening
in Ukraine and what he called the
soloists of War while a new U.N report
wants Russia to respond to evidence of
human rights violations is Russia
listening
[Applause]
[Music]
Vladimir Putin today called on Russians
to counter the West's economic
aggressions
Putin has not listened to outside voices
for 14 months and does not appear to be
listening now least of all to ukrainians
like Sergey lubevsky
they don't care he says they want to
kill as many people as they can
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto